hey what is up guys MTV HD here fresh
back from WWDC and we got a whole bunch
of different Apple announcements that we
usually do but I think the biggest of
those was definitely iOS 12 now in this
channel you probably already know I
usually do n't op new features of
android video when that comes out what
better time to start doing an iOS
version of that then when we got a bunch
of great new features so this is the top
5 new features in iOS 12 on the iPhone
so as you probably got the idea from the
last video it's not this wasn't like a
big design overhaul or refreshed like
that it really is just a bunch of added
new features that people have been
looking forward to for a long time so
number one is grouped notifications
finally as an Android user finally I
think that's got the loudest cheer
onstage when it got announced but ever
since it was shown on stage I've been
kind of curious exactly how it works to
get it in my hands and actually try it
is one thing versus just seeing it on
stage so it's actually the real deal
so as you expect all your notifications
from one app get grouped together it can
look pretty neat and organized in this
sort of a staff way and then you can tap
to expand and view all of them and then
you can act on each one of them one by
one if you want and when you're done
either at the top or the bottom of the
list you can collapse them back into
that little stack so it is immensely
better than before it still is a little
bit buggy and sometimes an iMessage at
wooden group notifications but generally
it's been working pretty well and I
still would also like to see in iOS the
ability to act on notifications while
they're in the notification tray without
leaving them so I'd do this on Android
all the time but that's that's probably
a couple years down the road either way
group notifications welcome to 2018 iOS
that's good to see number two is an
emoji it's somehow one of the biggest
headlining features of the iPhone 10 and
as far as I know it's still just for
iPhone 10 but an emoji has had a lot
added to it there's no new an emoji
there's a koala there's a tiger there's
a t-rex and there's a ghost and also
there's now there's tongues for all of
them there's tongue detection kind of
like snapchat has had for a while
including the skull everyone gets a
tongue so cool and then there's me emoji
which will let you create any number of
your own an emoji to look exactly the
way you want so this is my MIMO G
they don't exactly have my hair or
facial hairstyle so like this is as
close as I could get but your momochi
doesn't have to look like you it can
look like a totally different person or
a new character if you want as far as I
can tell there's no limit to how many
you can make but I like a video below of
customizing it you can go into infinite
detail of things like eyebrow shape and
makeup type and hairstyle and all that
kind of stuff it's pretty detailed I
also think the eye movement detection is
more impressive than the tongue the
tongue is just either in or out of your
mouth that's cool but the eyes are what
really gives it life the other hand
emojis before we're just beaded this is
a this is pretty good they work in
FaceTime now they also bumped the limit
up to how much video you can do with an
an emoji and iMessage to 30 seconds and
as you can see you can also superimpose
them on your own body so if you're into
that then that's nothing you can do
alright so number three is something
called screen time and I saw something
similar to this at Google i/o where it's
just basically directly addressing how
you use your phone how much you use your
phone and possibly whether or not you're
addicted to it and cutting down that
addiction now to be fair on the same
stage like 25 minutes later they had a
lady on an exercise bike trying to text
her friends while multitasking on her
SmartWatch so that message may have been
lost a little bit during the keynote but
that's kind of what they were going for
but it's actually really interesting it
shows you what you've used most on your
phone in the last couple hours the
screen has been on and then it lets you
set limits for certain apps so if you
want to make sure you only spend one
hour on Instagram you can tell it to do
that and then when you try to open the
app after that hours up it looks like
this it doesn't let you in unless you
click the button that lets you in but
still you get the point it also shows
you a really detailed breakdown of your
most used apps how many times you pick
up the phone during the day the average
per hour and which apps send you the
most notifications during the course of
the day how many times you pick up your
phone
it really is a wealth of information so
you can do with it what you want so
number four is Siri shortcuts now to be
honest I was looking forward to some
bigger improvements with Siri mainly
making it not bad but this is something
interesting essentially it'll allow you
to map any in-app action or any command
to any phrase you want literally any
phrase you want now it's still pretty
early for the eye
twelve beta so they don't have the
actual shortcuts app here yet which will
allow you to build as many of these as
you want but if you go in the settings
for Siri there's a couple that are built
in it kind of demonstrate how this works
so there's this custom shortcut to check
the Apple stock price in the stocks app
so that's a two level connection
literally it asks you to record any
phrase you want to trigger this so I
chose show me the money so now every
time I ask Siri to show me the money it
opens the stock app and checks Apple
stock price so you can see how this
would extend out to other apps and other
commands with other phrases not bad now
just fix the rest of Syria please and
the number five is all the new apps and
I know I mentioned earlier in this video
that there's not that many visual
changes with iOS 12 I guess that's kind
of a lie because in a lot of the stock
apps now they are overhauled they look
drastically different and there's
actually one new app so the iBooks app
is now Apple books and is supporting a
new design not not the super modern look
of a lot of the other things but that's
because it's books it's supposed to be
minimally distracting the news app is
redesigned this one with a more modern
UI and a stocks app is redesigned with
this slick user interface with Apple
curated news alongside the companies in
the stocks voice memos also got an
update and new logo as well but it's
like the simplest app ever but there you
go and then of course there's actually
the new app in iOS 12 possibly my
favorite edition which is called
the measure app and this is an AR kit
2.0 app so it's an augmented reality app
that lets you literally look through the
camera pointed at objects and measure
them measure how long or how tall or how
much volume they have and it's actually
pretty quality the only limitation seems
to be that it's definitely better with
smaller objects and with things that are
closer to you but I've tried it on a
number of things around the studio at
this point and it's definitely accurate
but there you have it there's some good
stuff in iOS 12 this time around and
there's also some legate's I didn't even
mention in this video one of them is
group FaceTime you can do a FaceTime
group call with up to 32 people
I couldn't demo it because I don't know
that many people with iOS 12 and if you
do this with someone on iOS 11 it kicks
them out of the FaceTime call but you
can do that in iOS 12 NASA FaceTime
calls the improvement to search in
photos is much more robust to the point
where they've put a search button right
there in the bottom of the app
encouraging you to use it it reminds me
actually a lot more of Google photos now
you can swipe
in iphone 10 to kill apps right away you
don't have to hold down and wait for the
little red minus sign to pop up anymore
that's massively more convenient I think
they heard our feedback on that one and
it's also now harder to take accidental
screenshots it's true so if you wake up
your iPhone with the power button and
the volume button at the same time that
would usually accidentally take a
screenshot of your lockscreen not
anymore so that's pretty awesome
Thank You Apple so that's iOS 12 that's
where we're at right now it will
continue to evolve it's in a public beta
form right now so there will be
additional beta bills that will come out
and I'm sure there will be more features
that surfaced so stay tuned on Twitter
to know about those when they come out
and also for good measure I'll link the
wallpaper the new iOS 12 wallpaper in
the description below because I know
stone is gonna ask about that be the way
that's been it until next time thanks
for watching talk to you the next one
peace